[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
soyez les bienvenus dans savouregard À
la une ce soir la gestion de la crise
sanitaire autopsiée par une mission
indépendante d'experts le professeur
Suisse Didier Pittet a rendu public son
rapport hier 4 mois d'audition de
compilation statistiques et de
comparaison internationale résultat la
France ne s'en sort pas si mal ça
faiblesse n'est pas médicale mais
administrative on en parle dans un
instant dans notre grand débat on
évoquera aussi la fin de l'école à la
maison dès la rentrée prochaine tous les
enfants en France devront dès trois ans
être
scolarisé Emmanuel Macron veut lutter
ainsi contre le séparatisme et les
écoles clandestines mais cette mesure
passe mal auprès des associations face à
face à suivre sur ce plateau enfin notre
grand témoin ce soir est une activiste
dans le grand bain de la politique quel
siège au Parlement européen avec les
insoumis Manon Aubry avec nous ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme hashtag
sévère n'oubliez pas pour réagir sur
Twitter tout de suite le grand débat
[Musique]
bonsoir Manon Aubry bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député européenne
membre de la France insoumise vous
portez de nombreux combats à Bruxelles
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
l'écologie on va en parler mais c'est
évidemment de la crise sanitaire dont on
va parler une fois de plus dans son dans
cette émission ce soir nous sommes en
direct le président de la République
s'apprête à prendre la parole aux
alentours de
19h55 toutes les annonces ont les
commentera en direct sur ce plateau mais
on va s'intéresser avant que le chef de
l'État ne s'exprime à l'heure de cette
deuxième vague un rapport à un pré
rapport pour être très précise pierre
parnex bonsoir très rapports que vous
avez consigné avec je le disais le
médecin épidémiologique Didier Pittet
médecin genevois médecin suisse c'est un
rapport qui vous a été commandé par le
chef de l'État on verra si Emmanuel
Macron le site ce soir et c'est un
rapport qui tente de faire le point sur
la de la crise sanitaire par la France
gestion comparée c'est une mine de
renseignements on va s'y attarder ce
soir bonsoir Julien borrowitz merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député la
République en marche de la Loire médecin
de profession et vous présidez la
commission d'enquête parlementaires à
l'Assemblée sur cette gestion de la
crise sanitaire parce Skype nous sommes
également en duplex avec avec Madame
Catherine Hill est-ce qu'elle est avec
nous Catherine il passe encore elle va
intervenir un peu plus tard elle était
bédiée biologiste et biostatisticienne
enfin bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
qui m'accompagne comme chaque soir et
qui va ouvrir le bal si j'ose dire avec
son billet d'actu comme tous les soirs
si j'ai bien compris c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir Stéphane si
j'ai bien compris Myriam finalement la
France ne sentir pas si mal face à la
crise du coronavirus alors évidemment
quand je dis ça il y a deux tiers de nos
téléspectateurs qui se retrouvent sur
leur fauteuil qui disent où est la
télécommande ce type raconte n'importe
quoi mais je vais changer de chaîne
parce que oui c'est délicat de dire que
la France va s'en tire pas si mal dans
damesure ou deux tiers des Français ne
feront pas confiance au gouvernement
face à la crise vous voyez on va faire
apparaître la cour vous allez voir que
elle a jamais été très haute cette
courbe mais alors là elle est de plus en
plus bas et on en est maintenant
aujourd'hui à 35% de confiance et
pourtant vous le disiez la France n'est
pas si mauvaise
au gouvernement que c'est le cas en
France
je suis chroniqueur à la télé j'ai
toujours une explication surtout c'est
le principe de mon job
[Rires]
la facilité ça serait quoi ça serait
pour expliquer cette défiance d'avoir
recours c'est à la psychologie des
peuples au tempérament national nous
sommes des Gaulois réfractaires
pessimistes pas facile à gouverner bon
je dis pas que c'est faux enfin bof
comme explication alors si c'est pas ça
l'explication c'est quoi alors à mon
avis c'est plutôt lié aux règles de la
Cinquième République donc je m'explique
les règles de la 5ème république elles
permettent en fait de faire élire un
président sur une base électorale assez
étroite si on prend le cas d'Emmanuel
Macron au premier tour il a obtenu 24%
des voix alors que parmi ces adversaires
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen par
exemple E2 on t'attend 40% et donc ça ça
joue beaucoup dans la confiance en fait
la confiance qu'on apporte qu'on accorde
au gouvernement et directement lié aux
opinions partisanes là ce sont des
c'était en avril je crois il y avait 39%
de confiance on voit bien que pour ceux
qui ont voté Macron c'est 80% de
confiance on le soutient à fond mais en
revanche pour ce qui est Mélenchon et le
Pen ça ne dépasse pas les 30%. donc tout
ça lié aux opinions partisanales il y a
quelque chose qui illustre bien aussi
c'est la confiance dans le professeur
Raoul qui était vraiment le personnage
médiatique qui incarnait la défiance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement donc quand on
prend la moyenne nationale c'est 52% de
français lui font confiance mais c'est
encore une fois très contrasté selon les
opinions politiques c'est à dire que
chez les supporteurs de Macron il y en a
30 % qui lui font confiance en revanche
il y a 60 % des des gens qui de la
France insoumise qui lui fait confiance
et plus de 70% au RN qui lui font
confiance et comment peut-il la regagner
cette confiance des Français alors ce
serait tenté de vous dire je sais pas
mais je suis chroniqueur à la télé une
réponse alors voilà ce que je vous
propose c'est de regarder encore une
fois les sondages quel est l'homme
politique le plus populaire en France en
ce moment Edouard Philippe qui
d'ailleurs a géré la première partie de
la crise d'où ma question est-ce qu'il
serait pas tant de rappeler doudou à
Mathilde alors ça ça n'y arrivera pas du
tout c'est une certitude merci Stéphane
on va s'arrêter sur un certain nombre de
graphiques qui a montré Stéphane à
l'instant je le disais pierre pernex
vous avez vous avez participé à ce
travail d'abord comment avez-vous
travaillé avec avec le professeur Suisse
Didier Pittet d'abord donc le président
de la République a installé la mission
fin juin donc il nous a garanti
l'indépendance le libre accès aux
personnes et aux documents et on l'a eu
complètement puisqu'on l'a vu pour la
mise en place on la présenter le rapport
d'état de la semaine dernière seulement
donc on travaille on se réunit à l'hôtel
Marigny deux jours par semaine on fait
les auditions qu'on voit de travail
pour pour ce type de réflexion on
travaille aussi en visioconférence la
semaine on analyse beaucoup de documents
donc on fait des entretiens de
personnalité évidemment concernées par
la gestion de la crise aussi on a une
vision internationale et on a plusieurs
chambres puisque il y a aussi Laurence
Boone qui est chef économiste qui est là
de Marie moulin qui est médecin et
philosophe donc on a le champ social les
champs économiques et on doit mixer ses
approches
ce pré rapport il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de choses on va essayer de
prendre dans l'ordre d'abord vous
appuyez sur un indicateur est-ce que
vous pouvez vous l'expliquer l'excès de
mortalité parce que ça a fait l'objet de
critique déjà voilà l'excès de mortalité
c'est ce qui est reconnu comme le plus
fiable pour apprécier la l'impact à un
moment donné d'une crise puisque c'est
une semaine donnée on va regarder
pendant les cinq années précédentes
comme il y a une mort dans un pays le
taux de mortalité et à partir de là on
peut calculer un nombre de morts qui
sera attendu si le mortalité changeait
pas et donc si le nombre de morts est
inférieur il y a pas d'accès de
mortalité si on a plus ça veut dire
qu'on a plus de mortalité par rapport
aux années de référence donc il y a eu
un phénomène et ici on voit bien que le
phénomène dans tous les pays de l'excès
de mortalité pendant la période de mars
avril mai c'est la crise covid alors on
va regarder un petit tableau très rapide
l'excès de mortalité en France et de
3,97 pour 100000 habitants en Autriche
ce sont les meilleurs élèves d'après
votre rapport ou pré rapport un tout
petit peu plus de 1 et pour les
États-Unis
pour cet excès de mortalité rapportée à
100 000 habitants je fais circuler la
parole dans un instant mais c'est
vraiment sur l'expert que vous êtes que
je voudrais m'appuyer c'est pour ça en
partie qu'on peut dire que la France est
dans la moyenne alors on mesure l'impact
sanitaire donc ça veut dire voilà que on
est dans la moyenne puisqu'il y a des
gens qui étaient beaucoup plus impactés
par la crise et d'autres qui l'ont été
moins alors après on aura des choses à
réfléchir c'est à dire l'intensité de la
crise quand la démarré qu'on l'a
identifié qui et sa chronologie dans le
temps puisqu'il y a des gens qui ont eu
plus de temps pour se préparer que
d'autres même si les États-Unis sont
mauvais exemple puisque en plus de temps
mais ils ont été frappés
les Allemands un peu plus tard j'ai
l'impression disons que nous on a eu un
énorme cluster au départ c'est vrai qu'à
à Mulhouse qui a quand même beaucoup
impacté les choses après voilà il y a
des circonstances qui ont été
différentes dans dans la stratégie mais
je pense que là l'indicateur lui est
pertinent puisqu'il donne l'impact sur
une population
vous êtes surprise ou pas au fond on
n'est pas les meilleurs mais on n'est
pas les plus mauvais ça dépend de quoi
on parle c'est ce que c'est pas une
coupe du monde de foot ou il faut
arriver premier parce que on parle de
vie humaine et en effet vous avez bien
fait de le préciser les pays européens
n'ont pas eu à affronter la crise
sanitaire de la même manière on l'a vu
aussi dans la coordination ou l'absence
de coordination dans la réponse
européenne que chaque état a pris aussi
a fait des choix politiques différents
ce que je retiens aussi du rapport quand
même qui a été qui a été présenté c'est
le manque d'anticipation de préparation
exacte des défauts manifestent
d'anticipation de préparer de
préparation et de gestion et c'est vrai
que j'ai un peu le sentiment que on est
en train potentiellement de reproduire
les mêmes erreurs qui ont pu être
produites pendant le premier volet ou la
première vague on l'appelle comme on
veut de la crise sanitaire et c'est vrai
que ce rapport tombe à point nommé au
moment où on attend les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron et peut servir de
guide pour la deuxième et j'ai le
sentiment qu'on répète un peu la même
chose aussi d'un point de vue
démocratique on a un espèce de monarque
qui va arriver et qui va dire les règles
c'est ça il y a pas eu de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale
sur l'anticipation la gestion et
notamment la question des livres
réanimation on essaye de savoir si on
est prêt par rapport à cette deuxième
Julien borrowitz pour appuyer sur sur
votre rapport à nouveau on peut on peut
montrer aussi un graphique qui montre
très bien que la courbe est considérable
à la fin de la courbe quand on regarde
par saison on a eu mais alors totalement
tort au début de penser que cette
maladie n'était pas sévère pour tous les
pays d'ailleurs on voit ce pic en 2020
quel qu'il soit c'est bien plus qu'une
grippette c'est totalement planté sur le
diagnostic au départ c'est bien plus
grave et ça tue plus
d'abord je crois que c'est toute la
problématique de cette pathologie et on
apprend au jour le jour à voir à quel
point il est difficile d'amorcer une
réponse définitive sur une pathologie
qu'on connaît pas mais le rapport le
pointe Est et moi c'est une question je
crois que je l'ai posé deux fois en
commission d'enquête j'ai jamais eu
vraiment de réponse c'est vrai que je
crois que le rapport le point c'est les
difficultés qu'on a eu au début à
identifier la pathologie et surtout à en
prendre effectivement l'ampleur la
mesure je pense que c'est irrité de la
façon dont on traite la grippe
habituellement avec le réseau Sentinel
enfin je sais pas si c'est comme ça que
vous l'aviez comparé mais en tout cas
nous dans les cabinets c'est ce qui se
passe c'est à dire qu'on avait testé au
début pour des raisons statistiques et
puis après par défaut on disait
forcément c'est un coronavirus parce
qu'elle la fièvre comme on le fait pour
une grippe et je pense que là l'erreur
s'est produite à ce moment-là ça y est
je le dis hein c'est toujours beaucoup
plus facile de le dire à posteriori
parce que moi-même je sais pas dans
cette position là il y a quelques mois
mais on a confondu c'est pas qu'on a
confondu c'est à dire qu'on a pris en
charge les choses comme pour une grippe
or ce n'est pas une grippe voilà et là
où on a dit bah voilà par défaut on ne
fait pas de test c'est forcément une
grippe voilà prenez un peu de doliprane
etc c'est ce qu'on fait habituellement
pour une grippe et on vous mènera un
travail etc là malheureusement retard à
on va on va y venir manque
d'anticipation problème de communication
aussi que vous pointez dans votre
rapport bonsoir Catherine Hill je crois
que vous êtes maintenant voilà en duplex
avec nous vous êtes épidémiologiste et
biostatisticienne vous avez notamment
travaillé à l'INSERM que pensez-vous de
la méthodologie de ce rapport on parlait
de l'indicateur de l'excès de mortalité
ça vous convainc comme comme outil
d'analyse
oui bien sûr tout le monde regarde ces
données et le nombre de morts par
million d'habitants c'est l'indicateur
ultime et il y a aucun problème il y a
pas de problème moi je non
la France s'en sort pas si mal dans dans
la moyenne
oui on peut trouver ça rassurant on
pourrait préférer dans les bons élèves
moi je pense que c'est un peu prématuré
de tirer les conclusions on est en plein
dans l'épidémie on sait pas comment
gérer la situation maintenant je suis
pas sûr que je sois convaincu de
l'opportunité de faire un rapport sur la
situation mais bon c'est ça c'est ça qui
a été demandé c'est beaucoup trop tôt on
est en pleine crise on sait pas du tout
comment la régler on voit bien on fait
pas du tout ce qu'il faut à mon avis on
va droit dans le mur le nombre de cas
augmente tous les jours et voilà et
pourquoi on va droit dans le mur
précisément
parce qu'on prend des mesures qui sont
largement insuffisantes qu'il faut c'est
tester massivement la population tant
qu'on n'a pas décidé de faire ça le
virus va plus vite que les autorités la
montée en puissance la montée en
puissance des des tests des nombres de
tests de sur le territoire ça ne vous
convainc pas on est un des pays qui
testent de plus aujourd'hui non mais non
ça c'est pas vrai enfin c'est le nombre
total de tests qu'on a fait ça c'est
décalé par rapport au nombre de cas
d'abord on ne sait pas combien il y a de
cas aujourd'hui en France on n'a pas
fait comme un Angleterre un sondage des
sondages sur des échantillons
représentatifs de la population je ne
sais pas s'il y a une personne sur 1000
qui est contagieuse ou 5 sur 1000 une
sur 1000 c'est ce qu'il y avait en
Angleterre pas au Royaume-Uni en
Angleterre il y a trois semaines et
enfin début septembre et fin septembre
c'était 5 sur 1000 donc on sait pas
combien de gens voilà on navigue on est
dans le brouillard on n'a pas ce taux de
contamination
on connaît quand même des choses il y a
un suivi qui s'est améliorer avec le
test mais c'est vrai que la stratégie de
test elle reste complexe et surtout
c'est d'arriver à relier toutes les
étapes au sein d'un indicateur du début
des symptômes jusqu'au à l'isolement de
la personne et après nous ce qu'on a
souligné aussi c'est l'importance
d'avoir une investigation des clusters
la plus précise possible pour comprendre
où est-ce qu'il y a des transmissions
comment elle se transmettent et
aussi avoir de la pêche
vous ne parlez pas trop de la pénurie de
masque en revanche sur le dépistage vous
dites que les laboratoires privées
publiques ont mal fonctionné que les
vétérinaires auraient dû venir en
renfort pour faire justement ces tests
disons qu'on est parti sur le système
d'organisation qu'on avait qui était
dans nos plans comme on l'a évoqué qui
était le plan pandémie grippal on l'a
déroulé dans les hôpitaux petit à petit
après les laboratoires privés n'avait
pas l'habitude les PCR il pouvait pas
faire le même type de TPSR au départ il
a fait avoir des kits standardisés pour
pour les inclure
la capacité ouais on est à monter
jusqu'à midi on est redescendu
maintenant autour de 700000 peut-être
quelque chose comme ça mais le tout
c'est les tests c'est quelque chose
c'est après l'usage qu'on fait des tests
et des résultats et l'efficacité qui est
associé donc il y a les délais il y a de
notre ordinateurs
[Musique]
vous vouliez rajouter quelque chose
mais on teste peut-être un million de
son fait un million 200000 tests par
semaine mais c'est totalement
insuffisant et les cas qu'on trouve sont
seulement une fraction assez faible de
l'ensemble des cas donc on cherche les
contacts des foyers des clusters mais
c'est cluster c'est que la partie
minuscule de l'iceberg donc toute la
circulation du virus échappe à notre
compréhension alors il est 19h48 le
président de la République va s'exprimer
dans peu près 5 grosses minutes
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire madame il
il faut tester il faut changer de
stratégie il faut décider qu'on va faire
un dépistage de masse qu'on va chercher
le virus dans toute la population pour
isoler les gens qui sont positifs c'est
pas ce qu'on fait en ce moment donc on
demande des renforts pour justement
ouvrir
un maximum de laboratoire et si on se
dirigeait vers un confinement puisque
couvre-feu pardonnez-moi
le confinement c'est juste congeler la
situation votre vous avez de la viande à
varier dans votre frigidaire vous la
mettez au congélateur quand vous la
ressortez elle se remet à pourrir le
confinement ça congèle la situation
temporairement et à la fin on se
retrouve dans la même situation qu'avant
exactement ce qu'on a déjà fait
dépister dépister dépister
avec des tests antigéniques faire des
tests groupés chercher le virus dans les
eaux usées il faut être inventif pour
trouver rapidement les gens qui sont
contagieux c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
trouve on trouvait en mai un cas sur 10
maintenant on trouve peut-être un cas
sur cinq donc on étudie les foyers mais
les foyers c'est une toute petite partie
de la circulation du virus on est en
deçà d'une politique de tests ambitieuse
elle a été ambitieuse mais c'est à un
moment donné je pense qu'il faut se
poser pour pas passer d'une stratégie à
l'autre etc sans arrêt se poser prendre
du recul c'est-à-dire vers où on veut
aller quel moyen on se donne qu'est-ce
qu'on a je pense que c'est un moment où
il faut prendre un petit peu de recul
par rapport à la stratégie donc je crois
que c'est important c'est une de nos
préconisations à ce stade là après notre
rapport la finalité c'est à la fin de
l'année c'est-à-dire se dire voilà quels
enseignement on tire et quelle
proposition on fait qui seront soumis à
la représentation parlementaire pour
savoir ce qu'ils veulent décider pour en
faire qu'en sorte lors de la prochaine
crise les décideurs politiques sont
meilleurs situations pour prendre leur
décision c'est ça
on a beaucoup parlé ici même dans cette
commission d'enquête des masques
j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde sur les lits
de réanimation parce que à l'aube de
cette deuxième vague on s'interroge
pourquoi n'a-t-on pas haussé nos
capacités sachant que une deuxième vague
arrivait je vous donne les chiffres du
de santé publique France aujourd'hui
le nombre de personnes actuellement en
réanimation santé publique France et de
1673 on est toujours à 5000 lits qu'on
peut monter jusqu'à 12000 mais pourquoi
c'est le même étage que pendant la
première vague d'abord on était monté
environ 10 000 sur la première vague là
on monte à 12000 simplement il vous aura
pas échappé que pour armer un lit
puisque c'est le terme
convenu il faut des professionnels or et
bien on peut pas former un professionnel
en quelques mois de soignants
vous vous en trouvez où là il y en a pas
là actuellement il faut les former on
s'est engagé depuis le début puisque le
numéro osus
des personnels de santé
et là quelle traduction concrète on va
en avoir dans chacun des hôpitaux dans
lesquels ils attendent et on voit à quel
point ils sont épuisés
sociales
simplement la question c'est est-ce
qu'on a les moyens d'augmenter le nombre
de lits nécessaires par rapport à la
première vague on lit des enquêtes dans
Le Parisien pour ne pas le citer que les
infirmiers veulent raccrocher à 40%. on
se dit il faut deux soignants parler de
réanimation cette fois-ci c'est tout le
territoire ou presque qui est touché par
l'épidémie donc on ne peut pas avoir
quelque part de renfort est-ce que c'est
un problème de renfort de soignants par
hôpitaux qui en ont le plus besoin mais
c'est ce que je disais c'est-à-dire
c'est un problème de personnel
globalement formé en France qu'on ne
peut pas multiplier démultiplier dans
d'autres hôpitaux ne sera pas possible
cette fois-ci mais c'est le principe du
plan blanc c'est-à-dire que déjà les
mobilisations maximale le plan blanc
faisait que les hôpitaux publics et les
privés travaillent ensemble dans mon
département en particulier ça a été un
des premiers à déployer le plan blanc
avec la clinique mutualiste la clinique
privée et fallait que les privés le CHU
mais juste
c'est vrai que il y a ce déploiement qui
peut pas se faire au delà de ça mais
juste une chose la question c'est aussi
de se dire avant tout faisons en sorte
que les gens n'y aillent pas en
réanimation c'est quand même ça la
priorité avant tout bien sûr
passer de 5000 à 12000 réanimation dans
le temps qui a été imparti c'était
quelque chose d'incroyable on y pensait
pas du tout que ce soit possible c'était
quand même extrêmement remarquable comme
vous l'avez évoqué il faut il faut des
professionnels on veut pas former des
professionnels aussi vite il faudra une
réserve sanitaire de paramédicaux qu'on
entretiendra enfin des choses qu'il
faudra aujourd'hui c'est pas la capacité
en lice c'est l'idée que plus on aura de
passer en covid dans les livres
animations mais en augmentant moi on
pourra prendre en charge correctement
les autres patients donc c'est ça qui
ont quand même pas dit
de soigner tout le monde l'objectif
c'est de soigner tout le monde c'est
d'éviter de déprogrammer si je peux même
un mot sur pour avoir une perspective
sur le temps long on dit que là on peut
pas recruter de soignants mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas on n'a pas attendu
cette crise sanitaire pour que les
soignants réclament davantage de moyens
pour les hôpitaux publics et davantage
de personnels publics et ce gouvernement
comme les précédents ont
systématiquement coupé dans les
personnels de santé et couper dans les
budgets de l'hôpital public et on en
subit directement les conséquences
politiques ça n'a absolument rien à voir
mais c'est à dire que moi
c'est pour ça que les personnels
soignants continuent de passer qui est
capable de passer de 5000 à 10000
animations
donc c'est bien beau de le de rehausser
dans l'urgence
qui arrive plutôt que voilà ce qu'il
faudra faire pour sauver le système
hospitalier à l'avenir Stéphane
mais on teste donc l'efficacité du
gouvernement nombre de morts il y a un
chiffre qui revient souvent c'est 90 %
des morts du covid ont plus de 65 ans
dans la mesure où on fait des ciblages
géographiques sur tel ville ou telle
endroit pourquoi on ne peut pas cibler
plutôt les populations puisque les gens
qui sont menacés ont à neuf fois sur 10
+ 65 ans pourquoi le critère d'âge n'est
pas une manière de cibler ceux qui faut
protéger donc éventuellement à qui on
demanderait de rester chez eux plutôt
que de bloquer la totalité du pays
envisagé
systématiquement leur donner la priorité
au personnel fragile il y a pas eu de
hiérarchie dans dans les tests par
exemple les cas contacts au début c'est
moins le cas maintenant était pas
priorisé dans les tests donc on peut
imaginer
des critères de priorisation alors on a
parlé au fond de la réponse médicale
vous dites que le problème n'est pas
médical finalement le système
hospitalier a tenu en revanche dans le
rapport pitay je voudrais qu'on
l'entende puisque ça m'a été fait mon
qui est la rencontrer cet après-midi il
estime tout même qu'il y a des ratés le
système français hospitalier mais le
système de santé en général est trop
compliqué écoutez
la structure de fonctionnement du
département de la Santé globalement en
France ou du ministère de la Santé est
un peu compliqué avec plusieurs agences
qui font tout un travail souvent
extrêmement performant mais qui ont de
la peine un tout petit peu à travailler
ensemble le labyrinthe administratif est
compliqué il complique beaucoup de
questions il y a des fois des délais
d'attente par rapport à des choses qui
paraissent extrêmement simples qui sont
beaucoup trop prolongées
la bureaucratie sanitaire c'est un des
éléments je crois que bon nous on vit
avec on la connaît bien mais c'est bien
d'avoir l'extérieur de Didier qui qui
pointe quand même qu'il y a des choses
qui pourraient fonctionner mieux donc ça
c'est un des enjeux ça comment on peut
se réorganiser on ira voir le modèle
allemand pour voir s'il y a des choses à
tirer de cette expérience et le faire
après voilà c'est une des difficultés
qu'on a qu'on a identifié c'est sûr
je viens boire au vide c'est ça c'est
effectivement les agences régionales de
santé qui ne se coordonnent pas avec
santé publique France ni avec le
ministère ni avec les territoires qu'on
a souvent mais c'est pas la première
fois que je l'entends sur une mission
mais c'est vrai qu'on a souvent ce
problème là avec des agences qui font
très bien leur travail mais la plupart
du temps mais en silo je vous prends un
exemple on parlait tout à l'heure des
masques santé publique France a mis 18
mois pour répondre pour savoir pour nous
dire que deux tiers des masques étaient
bons à à la poubelle 18 mois pour
nous répondre alors qu'ils sont en
charge de la gestion des masques et de
vous enrager en tant que
vous allez faire pour essayer de mettre
un peu d'ordre là dedans pour l'anecdote
on va j'ai demandé en tant que président
de cette commission d'enquête qu'on
aille visiter le site de
Vitry-le-François puisque c'est là où
sont stockés les masques parce que si
vous voulez nous comme on veut on nous a
décrit les lieux on a l'impression que
si vous voulez oui il y a un vieil
entrepôt qui prend l'eau avec des rats
qui qui passent à travers et un
pharmacien perdu au milieu qui est en
train de gérer ça j'exagère mais c'est à
peu près comme ça qu'on nous la décrit
donc on va aller visiter voir comment ça
se passe mais se dire qu'il y a deux des
masques qui sont passés à la trappe
parce qu'ils étaient périmés
aux régions qui arrivaient à trouver des
masques là où l'ethan y arrivait pas
commençons demandant à la Chine alors
que la Chine était souvent demandé aux
régions
où l'État a pris des masques sur des
stocks qui existaient ailleurs ensuite
l'État a fait importer des masques les
régions bon on souhaitait se mettre dans
le jeu
des territoires il y avait plus de de
fluidité et d'agilité
je n'ai jamais reçu de masque chez moi
personnellement malgré toute leur
renfort de pub du président
non je n'en ai pas vu et pourtant ils
étaient très beaux avec leurs petits
logos mais non il faut pas oublier non
plus le temps long on a un graphique
dans le rapport qui montre le stock de
masse qui diminue progressivement depuis
2011 donc c'est c'est pas quelque chose
qui arrive tout seul à la fin c'est vrai
qu'on a un problème en plus les qui sont
un propre à l'usage mais c'est
progressivement une culture qui a
diminué
sur les tests aussi vous expliquer que
il y a des plateformes informatiques qui
n'utilisent que des réactifs de la même
provenance qu'on n'arrive pas à
s'approvisionner ailleurs là aussi c'est
un fléchage
UBS en santé on a souvent ça les
industriels vendent leur appareil et le
consommable avec alors nous on avait
plus peut-être en biologie d'appareils
de ce type par rapport à un pays comme
l'Allemagne et c'est vrai que dans une
période aiguë où le concevoir un
manquait forcément un appareil captif ne
permet pas de faire des tests ça ça
amélioré au fil du temps puisqu'il y a
eu des plateformes acheter qui sont
beaucoup plus ouvertes vous avez
quelques pages aussi sur la mauvaise
communication de l'exécutif
expliquez-nous je crois que bon il y a
eu des choses qui n'ont pas été bien
compris dans l'explication les masques
on l'a expliqué la doctrine scientifique
qui portait les masques n'était pas
illogiques de dire que on regarde la
distanciation on a une hygiène des mains
on porte le masque on est malade c'est
ce qu'on pensait avec de la grippe après
on ne savait pas à cette époque on
aurait une pathologie qui se
transmettrait beaucoup chez les
asymptomatiques c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît c'est pas jusque là et
on a eu du mal à le découvrir par contre
ce qui n'a pas été bien expliqué c'est
justement pourquoi on changeait de
doctrine dire qu'on n'avait pas de
masque au début et dire qu'on avait été
capable de mettre des masques barrières
et les qualifier dans le fait de ne pas
être compliqué qu'elle gagnerait à être
amélioré cette cette communication après
je pense que pas vous excusez-moi madame
je vous en prie finissez dans la
communication il y a aussi faire
comprendre aux gens pourquoi on prend
des mesures c'est à dire quelle donnée
pourquoi je trouve des clusters là donc
il y a des clusters à Paris dans les
restaurants donc je prends des mesures
et parce que si les gens ne comprennent
pas et qui est pas d'incohérence et
c'est pas facile mais si je veux dire si
mon restaurant est ouvert à 21h ce qu'il
est moins dangereux qu'à 22h ou 23h
c'est ça et je pense que aussi c'est
donner confiance dans les mesures
barrières moi je vais au restaurant à
Paris parce que je suis parisien à
mi-temps quand les mesures barrières
sont respectées j'ai pas peur je me sens
en sécurité donc je pense qu'il faut que
les gens se disent si j'applique les
mesures je suis protégé et ça c'est
important ce sentiment d'insécurité créé
par ce que vous dites c'est
intéressant je trouve que c'est une des
conclusions les plus importantes du
rapport c'est comment le changement très
régulier de de doctrine et de alors on
peut imaginer et que c'est justifié en
partie parce qu'on découvre le virus
mais parfois ça a été aussi pour masquer
des pénuries et les masques et l'exemple
malheureusement le plus frappant tout ça
Hérode la confiance vous en parliez au
début la conscience des citoyens dans
les consignes qui leur sont donnés et
donc du coup après il faut pas s'étonner
que les gens les remettent en cause et
c'est difficile à comprendre pourquoi si
je peux me permettre de terminer c'est
difficile à comprendre pourquoi on peut
aujourd'hui aller manger dans un
restaurant et pas prendre une bière dans
ce cas là si c'est dangereux de prendre
une bière autant fermé aussi les
restaurants ou inversement et on a du
mal à comprendre
l'homogénéité la cohérence entre les
différentes contradictoires ou autres
variables d'une semaine à l'autre
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cela on a
bien vu d'ailleurs pendant le débat sur
ce top covid l'Assemblée nationale où on
a vu que la France insoumise était
vraiment très corporate là dessus pour
faire comprendre aux gens la cohérence
de l'importance de stop covid
application que le premier ministre n'a
pas télécharger non parce que nous on
est relativement cohérent sur
l'application
écoute Mélenchon mais bon voilà mais si
vous voulez absolument pas cohérent ce
débat qu'on a eu dans l'hémicycle
de l'État vient d'annoncer un couvre-feu
vous aviez quelques il a dit ce mot
quelques quelques réactions tour de
table je viens boire envie de vous y
attendiez on s'y attendait oui
inéluctablement alors c'est uniquement
dans les zones dites écarlate dans les
dans les métropoles mais donc un
couvre-feu entre alors normalement c'est
entre 21h et 6h du matin oui on s'y
attendait la question si vous voulez
principale c'était de trouver une
solution et même si c'est peut-être pas
forcément la solution idéale pour faire
en sorte que nous puissions limiter les
rassemblement privé puisque la
législation ne nous empêche d'intervenir
sur un rassemblement privé et c'est une
des solutions c'est pas forcément la
solution ni la solution idéale c'est une
des solutions
le confinement était la mesure extrême
c'est à dire on a bloqué l'épidémie
artificiellement elle est repartie quand
les gens sont ressortis donc ça veut
dire que il faut que les gens
comprennent que cette mesure elle est
prise parce que je pensais pour un peu
lui craignent un débordement du système
sanitaire donc c'est c'est un choix mais
si on change pas dans les pratiques si
on n'a pas une meilleure application des
règles barrières après ça va recommencer
donc je pense que c'est à mon avis ça
qui est important c'est qu'il faut qu'à
m'en donner les gens aient confiance
dans la prévention et qu'on leur donne
confiance et c'est pas facile le
couvre-feu est-ce que ça vous semble
si on me dit que pendant la nuit il y a
un grand nombre d'événements qu'on ne
peut pas contrôler et qui sont porteurs
de transmission là bon sens également
qu'il serait disproportionné en revanche
de se reconfiner oui on a quand même une
impression de déjà-vu sur la manière
dont s'est annoncé donc on a des
annonces un peu tonitruantes qui ont été
qui n'ont pas été débattus d'un point de
vue démocratique donc une partie sont
peut-être justifiées d'un point de vue
sanitaire mais pour qui une acceptation
collective il faut que ce soit cohérent
aujourd'hui les premiers cluster qui
sont investigués sont d'une part dans
l'entreprise privée d'autre part dans
les milieux scolaires et donc que
va-t-on faire dans les entreprises
privées et dans les milieux scolaires
pour s'assurer que la contamination et
la diffusion du virus et la plus petite
possible donc est-ce qu'on va rendre le
télétravail obligatoire moi j'attends
Emmanuel Macron là dessus je crois pas
encore qu'il soit exprimé est-ce que
dans les milieux scolaires et on va
faire en sorte de pouvoir véritablement
dédoubler et séparer éloigner le plus
possible les étudiants vous donne juste
les informations qui nous parviennent
puisque le chef de l'État est on est en
direct est en train de s'exprimer sur
TF1 et France 2 donc vos informations
étaient les bonnes 21h 6h du matin 8
métropoles et toute l'Île-de-France
vendredi minuit et ça va durer quatre
semaines est-ce que vous avez au fond
des éléments de précision sur ce
couvre-feu on ne peut plus dans ces
zones là marcher la nuit non plus sortir
effectivement sauf raisons
professionnelles ou raison sanitaire ça
veut dire que vous promenez votre chien
vous faites arrêter justement c'est pour
éviter parce que si vous voulez pendant
le confinement du fait du fait du fait
que ce soit un confinement complète
toute la journée évidemment il y avait
des horaires de sortie là on peut sortir
la journée donc à partir de 21h vous ne
sortez plus ça couvre-feu peine de vous
savez retrouver les modalités de la
vente qui est en lien avec mais il y
aura forcément une pénalité une
inéluctablement alors je pense que
quelques jours d'adaptation mais bon il
y aura une pénalité
ce mot déjà a quand même particulier
c'est vrai qu'on pouvait imaginer une
formulation
confinement nocturne
la communication voilà nous sommes en
guerre c'était en mars dernier ce mot de
couvre-feu aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
notre approche elle est notre vision
était un peu différente c'est à dire
c'est de bien identifier les
transmissions de faire respecter les
règles là où c'est important je crois
que en Gironde on l'a vu c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu quand même on était en zone
rouge il y a eu des mesures que le
préfet annoncé avec le maire en
particulier à Bordeaux et qui ont selon
le souhait de décentralisé en
particulier par les élus les choix et
les décisions et ça a marché la
population adhérer il y a des contrôles
des restaurants qui étaient pas
contrôlés qui étaient pas conformes ont
été fermés temporairement et ça a baissé
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se dire se
dire qu'on va surfer pendant de longues
semaines et moi sur une crête fragile
donc on aura un peu plus un peu moins et
il faut rester pédagogue et expliquer
aux gens et on verra vivre avec le virus
parce que c'est vrai que on se souvient
et ce sera peut-être le mode conclusion
de ce débat de ce mantra présidentiel
vivre avec le virus éviter le
reconfinement total c'était l'impératif
absolu vous pas l'impression que le
gouvernement change un peu de stratégie
tout de même parce que c'est ça qui est
difficile à lire non mais le problème
c'est que nous avons une recrudescence
de l'épidémie donc on est obligé
aujourd'hui de prendre les mesures
nécessaires mais la question de faire le
lien entre la partie épidémique médicale
et la partie économique et sociétale
c'est aussi ça qu'on est en train de
vivre aujourd'hui et on espère mais il
faut quand même aussi prendre les
responsabilités on parlait tout à
l'heure de prendre en charge la
pathologie au début à l'instant T au bon
moment et de bonnes de bonnes manières
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui pour éviter une saturation
de la réanimation parce qu'une
saturation de la rénémation ça veut dire
beaucoup de gens en réanimation donc
beaucoup de gens qui ont un risque de
décéder donc c'est notre rôle aussi
merci beaucoup d'avoir à la fois débattu
de ce rapport et commenter en direct ces
annonces je vous rappelle la principale
l'annonce du chef de l'État un
couvre-feu va être installé des
instaurer dès vendredi prochain dans 8
métropoles ainsi que dans toute
l'Île-de-France de 21h à 6h du matin les
théâtres les cinémas les restaurants les
bars seront fermés et la population
n'aura pas le droit dans ces zones
d'alerte maximale de circuler sous peine
vous disait Julien borvitch à l'instant
peut-être on verra ça dans les jours qui
viennent
d'amande merci à vous vous restez avec
nous Manon aubryon on va parler un petit
peu de vous de vos combats européens une
ancienne activiste voulait toujours dans
le grand bain de la politique c'est tout
de suite
[Musique]
Manon André on le sait la crise
sanitaire a tout saturé l'espace
médiatique mais aussi l'espace politique
vous êtes une insoumise Héli au
Parlement européen depuis maintenant un
peu plus de 1 an et demi voilà est-ce
que c'est pas très difficile d'être dans
l'opposition dans un moment pareil
est-ce qu'on est encore audible oui on
est encore audible et on essaie d'être
constructif vous savez au Parlement
européen le système parlementaire est un
peu différent il y a pas un parti qui a
une écrasante majorité donc un groupe
seul ne peut pas faire la majorité donc
on dialogue on échange on discute
parfois on crée des majorités
suspendus aux décisions de chacun des
gouvernements pas facile et en retourne
cette illustré par son monde de
coordination ces derniers mois l'Union
européenne dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire ce sont des États qui se sont
piqués les uns les autres des masques
des respirateurs et qui ont appliqué des
règles extrêmement différentes en
matière de test en matière de contrôle
dans l'espace Schengen et l'Union
européenne finalement a montré son pire
visage et donc nous on se bat aussi pour
dire que l'Union Européenne a une
responsabilité pour faciliter la
coordination pour protéger protéger
aussi d'un point de vue industriel
produire au sein de l'Union européenne
on va voir ça suffisamment de masse et
suffisamment d'outils pour faire en
sorte que l'Union européenne s'en sorte
le mieux possible et vous avez une
manière particulière de au fond pousser
vos combats dans l'arène de Bruxelles
votre portrait tout de suite avec les
mots Méric merci à vous avant toute
chose il y a un point à mettre au clair
non je n'ai aucun lien avec Martine
Aubry ou alors ma mère m'aurait menti
pendant beaucoup de temps non Manon
Aubry n'est pas la fille de Martine
Aubry elles vivent même aux antipodes
l'une de l'autre puisque Manon Aubry a
grandi à Saint-Raphaël dans le Var
beaucoup d'entre vous ne me connaissent
pas ou doivent se demander qui je suis
ça c'est ce que Manon Aubry a dû faire
quand elle a pris la tête de liste de la
France insoumise aux européennes une
petite vidéo de présentation car mano
Aubry n'est pas une professionnels de la
politique elle était pourtant bien
partie pour leader de manif à 15 ans au
lycée aujourd'hui
pour tous le même bac pour tous et voilà
on veut se battre un sacré potentiel
militant mais après si on se pose Manon
Aubry préfère rejoindre Médecin du Monde
puis Oxfam Elie devient spécialiste de
l'évasion fiscale
au Luxembourg les filiales au Luxembourg
c'est son dada y compris depuis quel
siège au Parlement européen nous vous
souhaitons une excellente retraite et
pour cela nous avons pour vous un petit
cadeau pour retourner dans votre paradis
fiscal vos amis les multinationales que
vous avez aidés pendant le luxe lix vous
souhaite une joyeuse retraite avec ce
cadeau merci beaucoup avec son passé
d'activiste Manon Aubry s'est capté
l'attention pour faire passer un message
comme lors de la Journée des droits des
femmes et nous continuerons de reprendre
en cœur l'hymne des femmes levons-nous
femmes esclaves et brisons nos entraves
debout debout
[Musique]
debouts de féministe elle a su gagner le
respect de ses camarades masculins c'est
une battante c'est une battante une
battante qui flirte parfois avec la
ligne rouge et qu'est-ce que tu fais là
il m'a puni il m'a mis un blâme un blâme
pour avoir invité le mouvement
extinction rébellion à un manifesté dans
l'enceinte du Parlement européen encore
une fois l'activiste derrière la femme
politique
l'activiste au fond vous inventez une
nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique c'est de l'agitation dans
l'hémicycle mais est-ce que c'est
constructif est-ce que vous êtes à faire
avancer les lois oui parce que derrière
il y a des propositions vous savez quand
je me bats contre l'évasion fiscale au
Parlement européen je fais des
propositions par exemple le fait que
Luxembourg l'Irlande les Pays-Bas qui
sont des paradis fiscales fiscaux au
cœur de l'Union européenne soit
considérés et soit listés sur la liste
officielle vous avez de l'Union
européenne de peser davantage de là où
vous êtes par rapport au combat que vous
me meniez au sein des ONG où on mobilise
beaucoup posé j'avais beaucoup hésité
avant d'accepter la proposition de la
force insoumise ça a duré même trois
mois j'avais d'abord dit non et ce qui
m'a à la fin poussé à accepter et à me
jeter dans la reine politique pour
laquelle j'avais pas mal de défiance
c'était de me dire que en fait après des
années de militantisme dans le milieu
associatif j'avais aussi accumulé
énormément de frustration qui était
celui très utile extrêmement
complémentaire parce que à la fin vous
savez quand je menais une campagne
contre l'évasion fiscale j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un soutien
populaire sur ces questions à la fin
c'est pas moi qui appuyé sur le bouton
et quand il y avait des lobbies qui
arrivaient à obtenir le dernier mot et
influencer certains députés moi j'étais
contribué à leur a changé aujourd'hui je
depuis là vous êtes à vous donner des
exemples concrets là on est en train de
voter en ce moment un rapport sur le
financement de la transition écologique
au niveau européen on a réussi à inclure
dedans qui est la taxe sur les
transactions financières donc pas encore
c'est la santé mais qui est dans le
rapport de taxer la spéculation
financière un autre des combats que je
porte c'est sur la régulation des
entreprises multinationales pour mettre
fin à leur impunité et là aussi on a
obtenu à ce que le Parlement européen et
l'Union européenne légifère pour faire
en sorte que les entreprises rendent des
comptes parfois d'ailleurs vous vous
créez des coalitions avec d'autres
groupes politiques c'est le propre du
Parlement européen petite question
politique pour terminer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui va se lancer c'est
imminent il a dit avant avant fin
octobre à la présidentielle il aura 71
ans 2022 c'est vraiment l'une meilleure
candidat de la gauche vous en avez un
autre à me proposer un meilleur à Paris
la régénération je pense que c'est un
moi ce que je dis pour cette campagne
j'étais pas là en 2017 j'ai pas fait la
campagne mais c'est que en 2022 il
faudra que ce soit une campagne
collective montrer que quand on remet en
cause la 5e République donc c'est un
avertissement Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
pas du tout un avertissement il connaît
mes positions là-dessus au contraire moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas
meilleur candidat que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et il a su aussi démontrer qu'il pouvait
créer un collectif autour de lui tant
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Parlement
européen alors vous allez voir
maintenant Aubry vous n'êtes pas la
seule à aimer les coûts d'éclat ma
journée à l'Assemblée c'est tout de
suite la chronique de Thomas des prés
clones
[Musique]
bonsoir Thomas bonsoir Myriam ravie de
vous retrouver ce soir vous nous parlez
d'un clash en plein débats budgétaires
exactement ça s'est passé hier soir dans
l'émission les députés examinent le
projet de loi de finances pour l'année
2021 et après le dîner le président de
la commission Éric verdt n'était pas
très content j'ai eu une sacrée surprise
tout à l'heure en découvrant une vidéo
de la France insoumise cette vidéo de la
France insoumise c'est François Ruffin
qui l'a publié sur sa page Youtube le
député de la Somme est très remonté sur
la façon dont sont jugés il recevable
certains de ces amendements
éliminé il recevable parce que ça crée
des charges et tout ça la cible de
François Ruffin c'est l'article 40 de la
Constitution qui empêche les députés de
créer des dépenses non financées dans le
budget mais pour l'insoumis là c'est une
décision politique il y a une
modification du simplement l'année
dernière de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
resserré
la recevabilité plus les riverds qui
veut pas que le débat dure trop
longtemps et donc la somme des deux fait
que ça tombe ça tombe ça tombe ça tombe
alors hier soir dans l'émission François
Ruffin n'était pas là mais le président
de la commission et le rapporteur du
budget oui et il lui aurait répondu on
pourrait faire passer le message à notre
collègue François Ruffin ici que ce
qu'il dit dans la vidéo est parfaitement
erronée puisqu'il confond le règlement
de l'Assemblée nationale avec la
Constitution française c'est ennuyeux
nous avions dit à vos collaborateurs que
ces amendements étaient irrecevables ils
ont été déposés quand même utilisé à des
fins politiques donc une mise en scène
c'est du mauvais théâtre c'est du
théâtre c'est pas du théâtre de
boulevard c'est du mauvais théâtre et ça
c'est inacceptable le face à face ne
sait bien sûr pas arrêter là ça a duré
une bonne partie de la soirée dans
l'hémicycle avec d'un côté Éric verd et
de l'autre les députés insoumis tout ça
c'est c'est un truc de Tartuffe vous
êtes des hypocrites l'article 40 est
intrigue d'hypocrite si l'article 40
supprimait les n'importe quoi vous serez
le premier être supprimé franchement
lisez deux minutes la jurisprudence de
l'article 40 et demander à vos
collaborateurs de vous les expliquer et
s'ils ne savent pas changer de
collaborateur vous considérez que nos
collaborateurs ne sont pas assez
intelligents pour vous c'est votre
problème mais moi je ne l'accepterai pas
ici bonjour François Ruffin vous avez
mis un sacré bazar hier soir dans
l'hémicycle c'est surtout les riverds
qui a mis le bazar voilà donc non non
moi j'ai fait mon travail mais Eric
wurtyr il dit que ce n'est pas de la
faute des commissaires ce n'est pas de
la faute de sa commission c'est la
Constitution qui veut ça la Constitution
manifestement vous savez les textes ils
peuvent être interprétés quand même il y
a une certaine élasticité dans
l'interprétation de la Constitution et
monsieur woert je dénonce pas du tout ça
provité qui mettra en cause la
probabilité de Monsieur hurt je dénonce
pas son incompétence
au contraire je pense qu'il est
extrêmement compétent il est extrêmement
compétent pour faire appliquer une
censure politique
ou non du juridique et ça et au nom de
la Constitution et ça il sait faire
voilà Myriam et selon nos informations
Erick Werth a écrit ce matin au
président de l'Assemblée Richard Ferrand
pour lui faire part de son indignation
face au comportement de François Ruffin
merci beaucoup merci Thomas double en
politique François Ruffin allez à
bientôt disons qu'on est assez
complémentaire et qu'on se rejoint un
peu on passe au deuxième grand thème de
cette émission la fin de l'école à la
maison je vous le disais la mesure a été
annoncée par Emmanuel Macron s'était il
y a deux semaines lors de son grand
discours sur le séparatisme et cette
mesure on va le voir tout de suite elle
est loin de faire l'unanimité face à
face tout de suite
[Musique]
face à face qui oppose ce soir
Anne-Christine Lang bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
la République en marche de Paris vous
défendez cette mesure qui sont consiste
à supprimer l'instruction à domicile
vous vous y opposez à cette mesure
Claudia Renault bonsoir vous êtes
président d'une association les enfants
d'abord qui défend l'école à la maison
25000 élèves concernés on va en débattre
tout de suite mais d'abord les clés pour
comprendre avec ce reportage de Maïté
Frémont qui a suivi une mère de famille
qui instruit ses deux enfants chez elle
regardez et c'est parti
ce lundi après-midi pour Léonard 7 ans
et sa sœur Joséphine 4 ans c'est atelier
peinture
le temps que ça dure il s'arrête quand
ils veulent quand ils veulent passer sur
autre chose qu'il faut sur autre chose
en guise d'institutrice leur maman un
peu plus de rouge encore un peu plus de
rouge et là j'ai mis que du rouge et la
salle de classe tout simplement leur
salon
[Musique]
Géraldine et son mari ont fait le choix
il y a plus de trois ans de faire
l'école à la maison ça s'est passé comme
ça parce que Léonard était assez en
souffrance par rapport à l'école il
pleurait les matins le soir donc
au bout d'un moment on n'avait pas
d'autres solutions et comme l'école
n'était pas obligatoire on la
déscolarisé en attendant de voir la
suite la suite Géraldine l'organise
mardi je on va la faire et le soir à 18h
j'ai ma batterie samedi je fais du judo
et le dimanche j'ai rien pour instruire
ses enfants elle met entre parenthèses
son métier d'orthophoniste et leur
concocte un emploi du temps sur mesure
là il y a un peu tout ce qui est
éducation cosmique donc voilà la
géographie l'histoire
la zoologie la botanique ici pas
d'apprentissage classique on apprend
monter ou encore à lire par le jeu quand
elle découvre la décision du
gouvernement d'interdire l'école à la
maison c'est un coup de massue on est
surpris quand même de tout ça ça tombe
sur nous surtout que voilà on est quand
même contrôlé chaque année on a
l'éducation nationale qui vient nous
voir une fois par an il y a aussi un
contrôle de la mairie pour voir dans
quel environnement vit l'enfant donc
c'est vrai qu'on comprend pas trop cette
décision et si l'école à la maison
devenait interdite en France la famille
pourrait envisager de quitter la
métropole
et aussi on a
le réveil
nous sommes pas pour nous réveiller tu
trouves un pari se réveille Géraldine et
son mari feront tout pour ne pas le
faire sonner l'année prochaine dans le
cas contraire Léonard rentrerait
directement en CE2 sans avoir suivi le
parcours classique Joséphine elle
découvrirait la maternelle
Anne-Christine Lang quand on regarde sur
portable on se dit mais pourquoi
interdire cela tout à l'heure de très
bien se passer
oui enfin je sais pas il faudrait
contrôler voir dans quelques années ce
que tout ça deviendra donc on peut
évidemment pas partir de cet exemple par
précise que tout les enfants qui ont
handicap des troubles du comportement
moteur les enfants en itinérance aussi
avec leur famille ou qui pratiquent un
sport de haut niveau ne sont pas
concernés par cette mesure il y a 50 000
enfants qui font l'école à la maison si
on enlève cela ça fait à peu près 25000
poursuivez pardonnez-moi oui c'est à
dire qu'en fait on sera amené le
ministre sera vraisemblablement amené à
définir effectivement très précisément
dans le texte les exceptions sachant
évidemment que les enfants voilà malades
ou porteurs véritablement avec un énorme
bazooka je pense que ce qu'il faut bien
préciser c'est que il y a eu plusieurs
étapes et dans le cadre de l'école de la
confiance dont j'étais là rapporteur on
a instauré l'école
l'instruction obligatoire à 3 parce que
on a le souhait de valoriser l'école
maternelle de dire que l'école
l'instruction à partir de trois ans
c'est absolument polarisation
d'accord mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ça s'inscrit quand même dans un
processus où on a à cœur le ministre et
nous-mêmes de valoriser les
apprentissages entre 3 et 6 ans l'école
enfin l'instruction est devenue
obligatoire donc il y a un processus
donc là effectivement il y a une
nouvelle étape qui instaure l'école
obligatoire à 3 ans parce que on
considère que l'école de la République
doit être le lieu privilégié
de de des apprentissages parce que c'est
le lieu avec enfin je veux dire de
personnel compétents ou l'enfant
rencontre d'autres adultes d'autres
enfants se confrontent à des règles fait
tout un apprentissage qui est qui ne
peut être dispensé dans le meilleur
conseil conditions à l'école je vous
rappelle que c'est une mesure qui a été
annoncée pour lutter contre les écoles
clandestines on va réécouter tout à
l'heure le son d'Emmanuel Macron à ce
sujet là est-ce que vous madame Renaud
qui défendait ses parents là vous
estimez un peu victime collatéral dans
cette affaire oui on a complètement
l'impression d'être des victimes
collatérales je voulais juste préciser
que je suis pas présidente de
l'association les enfants d'abord je
suis membre actif mais pas présidente
les parents qui font l'instruction en
famille ont très à coeur de participer à
la société à la République aux valeurs
de
du vivre ensemble dans lesquels quand
même à l'altérité et en tout cas il y a
tout un dispositif de la mairie et de
l'éducation nationale qui veille à
vérifier que ces familles justement
respectent tout ça mais qui sont ces
parents parce que on a l'impression
qu'ils rejettent le modèle éducatif
traditionnel qui veulent de
l'alternative on entend dire qu'il y a
des antibacts famille ces familles que
parfois on n'est pas loin des familles
très variées
de pédagogie
c'est un peu les années 70 on est en
plein dans les livres enfants de sommeil
mais ça
voilà
qui sont préférés par ces familles il y
a vraiment une très grande diversité il
y a 7 ou 8 rassemblements à l'échelle
nationale des collectifs et des
associations qui rassemble les familles
il y en a qui veulent faire qui
s'appelle l'école et la maison pour
avoir des apprentissages
scolaires mais
dans un style plus familial et avec une
attention plus familiale et puis il y a
un effet un certain nombre de parents
qui ne se reconnaissent pas du tout dans
la forme scolaire qui a dire quoi les
notes l'évaluation oui les notes
l'évaluation obligation d'un système
sans note oui d'autant que mais d'autant
que plein de recherches montrent et
plein d'écoles alternatives
qui sont avec des systèmes pédagogiques
autres là on est dans autre chose
ça fait 80 ans que des écoles
alternatives ou des recherches de façon
de travailler alternative existe et
fonctionne
donc ça veut dire que les parents sont
quasiment à temps plein au moins un des
deux parents avec avec leurs enfants
pour faire cette école à la maison à
l'école Anne-Christine ce que je
voudrais dire quand même ce qui est
important c'est que en fait
effectivement comme je le disais il y a
un processus parce que nous on croit
l'école de la République en collectivité
pour les raisons que que j'ai évoquées
on note aussi que ces dernières années
il y a une explosion de l'école à
domicile de l'école à domicile
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a des
élèves qui ne sont tout simplement pas
scolarisés ou déscolarisés
et effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'enfants qui pour des raisons
religieuse notamment liés à l'islam
radical
refuse l'école de la République refuse
les règles qui sont imposées et les
apprentissages qui sont proposés aux
enfants il y a des écoles de fêtes des
écoles clandestine et que donc on est
effectivement dans une volonté de lutter
à la fois contre l'obscurantisme parce
qu'on pense que les enfants ont droit à
une éducation complète avec toutes les
disciplines l'ouverture d'esprit
l'esprit critique etc je vous proposerai
l'enfant à bénéficier de tout ça je vous
propose de réécouter le chef de l'État
je vous donne la parole juste après mano
Aubry pour resituer au fond l'objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron avec cette
interdiction
des parents d'élèves qui viennent voir
directeur ou la directrice d'école et
qui disent
le cours de musique s'est terminé sinon
il ne reviendra plus la piscine avec les
autres c'est terminé sinon il ne
reviendra plus et ensuite des
certificats pour allergies au chlore qui
sont donnés puis des absences répétées
et enfin la déscolarisation nous allons
l'inscrire au CNED ce sera très bien
fait c'est plus simple pour nous ces
enfants ne vont pas au CNED parfois il
ne reçoivent aucune éducation mais ils
vont dans des structures qui ne sont
nullement déclarées la semaine dernière
nous en avons encore
identifié une enseigne Saint-Denis des
structures très simples
des murs presque pas de fenêtre des
enfants qui arrivent à 8h chaque jour
qui repartent à 15 heures
des femmes handicap qui les accueillent
et lorsqu'on les interroge
des prières certains cours voilà
le renseignement c'est une réalité nous
devons la regarder la nommer en face
voilà Manon est-ce qu'il fallait frapper
fort comme la flèche de l'État en
interdisant l'école à la maison pour
interdire tout simplement éradiquer ces
écoles clandestines alors c'est un sujet
intéressant après je sais je suis pas
sûr que ça fasse partie du package
séparatisme d'ailleurs la loi a changé
de nom au passage deux éléments
je pense elle peut avoir des éléments
intéressants par contre il faut être
vigilant sur des personnes qui seraient
qui n'entreraient pas dans les
exceptions qui sont possibles je crois
que vous entendez madame Renaud par
exemple
des enfants qui sont harcelés à l'école
qui rentreraient pas forcément dans les
questions sanitaires et qui à mon sens
mériteraient d'être scolarisé à la
maison au moins temporairement donc il
faut penser à ces exceptions et le
dernière chose que je voulais dire c'est
que si le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron
se suscitant de la scolarité pour tous
un attachement à l'école républicaine
que je partage et qu'on partage à alors
j'ai envie de lui poser la question quid
de tous les enfants qui sont
déscolarisés alors qu'ils demandent à
être scolarisés pensez aux mineurs
isolés étrangers aux enfants en grande
précarité aux enfants en situation de
handicap qui n'ont pas le droit à
l'école à la scolarisation et pour tous
même pas on n'a pas de papier plus de
100000 enfants qui sont disques
scolarisés sans qu'ils le veuillent et
je pense que ça doit être peu de temps
j'entends je voudrais qu'on reste sur le
sujet
dans le cadre de l'école de la confiance
nous avons personnellement fait voter un
amendement qui oblige les maires à
inscrire les enfants sans autre
autorisation
madame Claudia Renault qu'est-ce que
vous réclamez qu'est-ce que vous
demandez à ce gouvernement à la majorité
que vous avez en face de vous
l'arsenal existe c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
des visites de la mairie les visites de
l'inspection qui s'est déjà contrôlé ça
suffit on est bien contrôlé et il
faudrait peut-être donner davantage de
moyens aux maires et au rectorat pour
que il puisse faire ses contrôles là
mais il y a eu des guerres scolaires
dans le pays vous voulez manifester vous
êtes peu nombreux si on regarde les 25
c'est une possibilité pour un certain
nombre de familles dont l'enfant est en
souffrance un an il y a une étude en
cours de Philippe Bongrand qui montre
que la moitié des déscolarisation dure
un an ou un an et demi ou deux ans enfin
c'est pour une période temporaire
qu'est-ce que vous répondez pour
conclure pour conclure je pense
qu'effectivement il y a une réflexion à
mener sur les exceptions les évictions
temporaires etc
par exemple du harcèlement bon c'est
vraiment une priorité du ministère qui a
voté qui a été de choses extrêmement
ambitieuses avec des référents etc des
formations des personnels sur le
harcèlement il y a tous les cas qu'on
connaît de phobies scolaires etc et
évidemment
nous on défend véritable quelque chose
en dehors de studio en fait vous voulez
interdire le de la forme qui est
terminée malheureusement le temps qui
nous est imparti voilà est terminé on va
redonner du temps à se débat qui ne fait
que commencer puisque il y a un projet
de loi qui se prépare merci Manon Aubry
merci mesdames très belle soirée et à
demain merci
[Musique]